It turns out that interval II is false and interval III is true. Let's see why.
I think for the second interval, the easiest number to check would be x equals
0. If we let x equals 0, then we know that we'll have negative 12 is greater
than 0. We know this is a false statement. So, this means that none of the
values between negative 3 and positive 4 would satisfy our original inequality.
We would exclude these values from our solution set. For interval III, I'm
going to choose the number x equals 5. Now, you could have chosen any number,
like six, eight, ten, even 14. You just want to choose one number to test in
this interval to see if it makes our inequality statement true. So plug in x
equal 5. I get the statement 8 is greater than 0. I know this is true, which
means that all of these numbers satisfy our original condition. Great work if
you found this to be false and this interval to be true.